je vais être honnête ouais j'ai failli
me suicider mais ne
fait pas ça on a besoin de toi c'est
vrai qu'on commence et quand j'ai quitté
un huissier de justice non je ne savais
pas quoi faire de ma vie j'avais pas un
rond toute façon quand tu vas pas pris
ben je vous connaissais pas on n'aurait
pas ce privilège est toujours de maputo
m et non c'est vrai et j'avais pour
louer une voiture bon cela l'idéal un
peu de fric de deux messieurs je vais
partir le centre dirais-je lui une
bagnole et je voyais la côte vous avez
comme dans les films et jouer la cote
défilé devant moi pour aller jusqu'à
mach ramène tout ça et je me dis bah je
vais je vais foncer mais vraiment et je
suis en larmes et on aime j'ai jamais
raconté bernard c'est que ça fait
quelque chose
ça faisait quelque chose tu te louper
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai heureusement sans déconner en
original vidéo
après fort bourguiba et nous on aurait
fait mais non le problème si vous voulez
c'est que quand vous avez plus d'argent
que vous rentrez plus en fonction c'est
quoi ça n'arrive pas ça m'arrivait ah
oui j'ai même pensé à me suicider c'est
vrai bon à moins cher moins cher mentale
matin sa survie nicolas tu me connais
j'ai un mental oui mais moi je vous ai
connu pas bien du tout exactement alors
il va connu avant de chez vous
d'ailleurs vous vouliez même me vendre
une table ou un truc là
j'ai eu vent des raquettes de tennis et
tous les jeux vous avez emmené en
voiture est branchée sur boulogne à
l'époque bon entier chez vous et vous
rentrez les missions antérieures servis
de noms mais quand même il est né à la
rue totalement est ce que certaines fois
je vois des gens qui vivent au village
d'um était à la rue magenta il a eu un
moment de sa vie où il était comme non
le soleil et tu l'as été ou pas
qui l'a fait
quand même un peu dit
c'est mon niveau de 6 mois
raconté c'est lui qui a lancé touche par
des comptes on avait lancé sa dans une
cafétéria
n'avait pas de voiture et qu'on a été
dans une cafétéria mais les écrits sur
un coin de nappe cappuccino
à la batte ne sait rien il courra plus
toi je viens d'une cafétéria suresnes
exactement